Hallo, mein Name ist Olivia Lanes und ich bin Forscherin und Ausbilderin bei IBM Quantum. Dieses Video markiert den Start einer
brandneuen Serie auf dem Qiskit YouTube-Kanal und unserer Lernplattform namens Quantum Computing in der
Praxis. Kurzum, in dieser Serie werde ich dir zeigen, wie du einen Quantencomputer, der gerade jetzt existiert, zu seinem
vollen Potenzial nutzt. Es gibt bereits Milliarden von Videos im Internet über Quantencomputer und ihr zukünftiges Potenzial oder über theoretische Konzepte
hinter der Quantenberechnung, die ebenso wichtig sind — siehe zum Beispiel Understanding Quantum Information and Computation,
moderiert von John Watrous. Aber in diesem Kurs werden wir annehmen, dass der Lernende vielleicht etwas mehr weiß
als in der Vergangenheit, und wir werden technisch sehr weit gehen. Das liegt daran, dass wir im vergangenen Jahr — und zum
Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme schreiben wir 2024 — einen Wandel gesehen haben, einen Phasenübergang sozusagen, in eine neue Ära der
Berechnung. Quantencomputer nähern sich endlich dem Punkt, an dem sie nützlich sein können. Obwohl das Experimentieren mit
kleineren Circuits und Quantencomputern notwendig war, um unsere Community im Umgang mit diesen Maschinen zu schulen, hat niemand Experimente durchgeführt,
die nicht auch auf normalen klassischen Computern ausführbar gewesen wären. Aber seit heute haben wir eine Ära der
Quantum Utility betreten. Und was ist Utility, fragst du? Es unterscheidet sich von Quantum Advantage, das man als den
Punkt verstehen kann, an dem Quantencomputer klassische Computer bei einer sinnvollen Aufgabe übertreffen. Stattdessen bedeutet Utility,
dass sie beginnen können, miteinander zu konkurrieren, und das ist der natürliche nächste Schritt in der technologischen
Evolution. IBM veröffentlichte eine Arbeit, die zum ersten Mal letztes Jahr zeigte, dass ein Quantencomputer verwendet werden konnte, um
ein physikalisches Modell zu simulieren und mit modernsten klassischen Simulationstechniken zu konkurrieren. Er übertraf sogar die
Brute-Force-Versuche und gab Forschern einen neuen Weg für die Forschung. Warum passiert das alles also
jetzt? Nun, in den letzten Monaten hat IBM Quantenprozessoren mit über 100 Qubits allgemein verfügbar gemacht. Wenn du
bereits Nutzer bist, hast du vielleicht bemerkt, dass wir viele unserer kleineren Prozessoren abgeschaltet haben, um Platz für diese größeren Chips zu machen, und wir fanden es wirklich
wichtig, das zu tun, weil einige Qubit-Zahlen noch klassisch ohne Probleme simuliert werden können, also gibt es
keinen echten Vorteil durch die Nutzung dieser Chips. Aber bei 100 Qubits ist das nicht mehr der Fall — sie können
nicht klassisch simuliert werden. Es ist auch wichtig zu erwähnen, dass es Simulatoren gibt, die
im Wesentlichen Computerprogramme sind, und sie können einiges Verhalten von Quantensystemen nachahmen, einschließlich Rauschen. Aber bitte
übersehe nicht die Tatsache, dass ich nachahmen gesagt habe. Simulatoren sind keine Quantencomputer. Sie können nicht die Ergebnisse produzieren, die
Quantencomputer in dieser Größenordnung können. Aber sie sind trotzdem ein wichtiger Teil unseres Test-Workflows. Das war also eine sehr
ausführliche Antwort auf die Frage oben auf dieser Folie: Was ist praktisches Quantum Computing? In diesem Kurs werde ich dir realistische
potenzielle Anwendungsfälle für Quantum beibringen und die besten Praktiken für das Ausführen und Experimentieren auf diesen größeren
Prozessoren von heute. Also für wen ist dieser Kurs gedacht? Fangen wir mit einer Einordnung an.
Zu Beginn: Dieser Kurs ist für alle, die neue Anwendungen für Quantencomputer entwickeln wollen,
wissen möchten, wie sie ihre aktuelle Arbeit skalieren oder lernen wollen, wie sie Quantum in ihre bestehenden Workflows integrieren. Ich habe vorhin
erwähnt, dass dieser Kurs sehr praxisorientiert sein wird und wir kaum über theoretische Aspekte sprechen werden. Wir
erwarten, dass du mit einem grundlegenden Verständnis von Quantenberechnung hereinkommst. Aber wenn du noch nicht ganz dort bist, keine Sorge — schau dir einfach
die ersten paar Episoden von John Watrous' Kurs an und du bist bereit. Wir möchten auch sicherstellen, dass die Zuschauer wissen,
dass dies nicht nur ein Kurs für Physiker oder Informatiker ist. Diese beiden Fächer haben Quantum Computing
in den letzten zehn Jahren ziemlich für sich beansprucht. Wir möchten sicherstellen, dass auch andere, die mit großen Datenmengen oder
Simulationen arbeiten, wie Ingenieure, Chemiker und Materialwissenschaftler, wissen, dass dieser Kurs auch für sie ist. Zusammenfassend richtet sich dieser
Kurs an ein breites Publikum und wir hoffen, dass du bis zum Ende dabei bleibst. Nach Abschluss dieses Kurses wirst du
in der Lage sein zu verstehen, wie man einen Utility-Scale-Job über Qiskit Runtime erstellt und ausführt, einschließlich des gesamten Workflows.
Du wirst die wichtigsten Arten der Fehlerminderung verstehen und auch wahrscheinliche Anwendungsbereiche kurzfristig kennen. Du wirst auch in der Lage sein,
all diese Algorithmen in Qiskit auszuführen, und schließlich erwarten wir, dass du Rauschen verstehst und wie man damit umgeht.
Also legen wir los. Quantum Computing ist eine aufregende neue Technologie in einem frühen Entwicklungsstadium, aber es ist nur
ein Kapitel in der Geschichte der Berechnung, die Tausende von Jahren zurückreicht. Ich denke, es ist wichtig, diesen
Kontext zu verstehen, weil er das, was wir hier vorhaben, etwas intuitiver, vorhersagbarer und weniger
nach Science-Fiction macht. Seit der Antike haben wir als Menschen Berechnungen durchführen müssen, oder
anders gesagt, Informationen nach bestimmten Regeln und Einschränkungen verarbeiten müssen, um
Kommunikation, Bauwesen, Handel, Wissenschaft und alle anderen Aspekte unseres Lebens zu ermöglichen. Wir haben die physikalische Welt
um Hilfe gebeten, und durch geniale Entdeckungen haben wir Geräte gebaut, die uns beim Rechnen helfen. Vor langer Zeit waren Geräte
aus Holz, Knochen, geknoteten Seilen gemacht, und sie speicherten Informationen und ermöglichten Berechnungen ganz anders als wir es heute
tun. Mechanische Geräte aus Hebeln, Zahnrädern und anderen Maschinen entwickelten sich von frühen astronomischen Uhren bis zu
Taschenrechnern bis hin zu ausgeklügelten Rechengeräten wie Differentialanalysatoren, die Gleichungen mit Rädern und
rotierenden Scheiben lösten. Sogar die Technologie des Schreibens hat eine wichtige Rolle in der Geschichte gespielt, indem sie Menschen ermöglichte,
Berechnungen durchzuführen, die sie sonst nicht hätten machen können. Wenn wir heute an Computer denken, neigen wir dazu, an
elektronische Digitalcomputer zu denken, aber das ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich junge Technologie. Elektronische Digitalcomputer
wurden erstmals in den 1940er Jahren gebaut. Das älteste bekannte Werkzeug für Berechnungen ist tatsächlich der sumerische Abakus,
von dem Experten glauben, dass er in Babylon zwischen 2700 und 2300 v. Chr. erfunden wurde. Das ist wirklich
lange her. Aber wir haben immer mehr über die Natur verstanden, von Archimedes über Euklid bis
Einstein, und unser Bedarf an mehr Rechenressourcen ist explodiert. Heute haben wir Supercomputer, die im Grunde
viele sehr leistungsstarke Computer sind, die parallel geschaltet sind. Sie sind eines der besten Werkzeuge, die die Menschheit hat, um
schwierige Probleme zu lösen. Aber es gibt immer noch viele Probleme, die selbst diese riesigen Computer niemals lösen werden können.
Mehr dazu später. Also haben wir festgestellt, dass Menschen seit Tausenden von Jahren Physik und Natur nutzen, um zu rechnen,
und um uns bei unserem nie endenden Streben zu helfen, mehr und größere Dinge zu berechnen. Du kennst vielleicht schon
Moores Gesetz. Es ist eigentlich kein Gesetz, eher eine Beobachtung — der Gesetz-Teil ist meiner Meinung nach etwas
augenzwinkernd gemeint. Die maximale Anzahl von Transistoren in einem integrierten Schaltkreis, also einem Computerchip,
verdoppelt sich etwa alle 2 Jahre. In den letzten 5 Jahrzehnten haben wir das nicht nur beobachtet, sondern auch großen Nutzen daraus
gezogen. Mit mehr Transistoren können wir mehr und schnellere Berechnungen durchführen. Das ist im Wesentlichen dafür verantwortlich,
dass Computer im Laufe der Zeit immer leistungsfähiger und kleiner werden. Allerdings gibt es schlechte Nachrichten: Moores Gesetz stirbt.
Experten sind sich uneins, wann Moores Gesetz sein endgültiges Ende erreicht, aber einige sagen, es sei bereits geschehen. Obwohl wir vielleicht nicht
genau wissen, wann wir unsere Grenze erreichen, wissen wir, dass es irgendwann unvermeidlich ist, denn manche Transistorteile
können physikalisch nicht noch kleiner gemacht werden. Du kannst keinen Transistor bauen, der kleiner als ein Atom ist. Das
ist natürlich völlig unphysikalisch — klingt albern, aber das sind die Grenzen, mit denen wir tatsächlich arbeiten. Also was
machen wir? Einfach aufgeben und sagen, das ist so gut wie es wird? Nein, das haben Menschen noch nie getan. Zum Glück ist die
Quantenmechanik ins Gespräch gekommen. Quantenmechanik wurde in den 1920er Jahren entdeckt, und seitdem war die Welt
buchstäblich nie mehr dieselbe. Wir könnten stundenlang über die revolutionären Entdeckungen reden, die
gemacht wurden, aber das ist nicht wirklich der Fokus dieses Kurses. Stattdessen möchte ich klarstellen, dass wir wissen, dass
Quantenmechanik und Computing bereits miteinander kompatibel sind. Die Erkenntnisse und das Verständnis der Natur,
die wir aus der Quantenmechanik gewonnen haben, haben zum Teil unsere modernen Computer möglich gemacht. Ohne Quanten-
Mechanik hätten wir wahrscheinlich nicht einmal die Festplatte verstanden oder erfinden können, zum
Beispiel. Quantum Computing ist einfach der nächste natürliche Schritt in dieser Evolution.
Aber Berechnung existiert nicht einfach im Vakuum. Information braucht ein Medium.
Das Berechnen von Informationen nutzt die physikalische Welt und beeinflusst sie auch. Das setzt Grenzen für das, was physikalisch überhaupt
möglich ist. Aber die Natur und die physikalischen Grenzen zu verstehen, ist eigentlich das Ziel der Physik als
Disziplin. Also waren Physik und Berechnung in gewisser Weise schon immer miteinander verflochten. Ralph Landauer, ein Informatiker und
IBMler, erkannte vor Jahrzehnten, dass Information physikalisch ist. Anders ausgedrückt: Information ist keine
abstrakte Entität, sondern existiert nur durch physikalische Darstellung. Landauers Prinzip stellt eine Verbindung
zwischen Information und den Gesetzen der Thermodynamik her. Aber tatsächlich gibt es viele Verbindungen zwischen Physik und
Berechnung. Klassische Physik war alles, was wir bis vor kurzem erforschen konnten. Aber mit der Entdeckung der Quanten-
Mechanik stehen wir jetzt an der Schwelle, eine völlig neue Art zu rechnen erschaffen zu können. Und das ist großartig, weil
klassische Computer nur annähern können, was tatsächlich in der Natur geschieht, und in manchen Fällen ist diese Annäherung sehr
begrenzt. Das liegt daran, dass es wirklich, wirklich schwer ist, Maschinen, die den Gesetzen der klassischen Physik folgen, dazu zu bringen,
die Gesetze der Quantenphysik zu approximieren. Und die Natur ist nicht klassisch — sie ist quantenmechanisch. Eine Analogie, die dir helfen könnte,
zu verstehen, ist ein Windkanal. Strömungsdynamik ist notorisch schwer zu simulieren und mathematisch vorherzusagen,
sogar etwas so Alltägliches wie ein Auto, das durch Wind fährt. Autohersteller fanden, dass es tatsächlich
zu teuer und unpraktisch war, diese physikalische Interaktion beim Autodesign zu simulieren. Stattdessen
bauten sie einen echten Tunnel, der Wind hindurchbläst, und fahren einfach ein Auto hinein
und schauen, wie es sich verhält. Das ist analog zu dem, was ich meine, wenn ich sage, klassische Computer approximieren die
Natur nur schlecht, und manchmal ist es zu aufwendig, es überhaupt zu versuchen. Anstatt den Wind zu simulieren,
erzeugen Forscher ihn einfach nach. Ähnlich müssen Quantencomputer die Naturgesetze auf
molekularer Ebene nicht approximieren, weil sie diesen Gesetzen intrinsisch folgen. Sie müssen nichts simulieren — sie emulieren es. Und
dieselben Schwierigkeiten treten auf, wenn wir Batterien oder chemische Reaktionen simulieren, was uns zum nächsten
Abschnitt bringt: Quantum Computing — wofür ist es gut?
Warum sollten wir überhaupt darüber nachdenken, Quantenmechanik und Computing zu kombinieren? Nun, es gibt bereits viele
Probleme, die zu schwierig, zu rechenaufwendig sind, selbst für unsere modernsten Supercomputer.
Vielleicht sind das Probleme, auf die sich nur Forscher super konzentrieren, aber ihre Auswirkungen könnten alle Teile der
Welt berühren. Diese Probleme, bei denen klassische Computer stecken bleiben, sind Dinge, auf die wir als Gesellschaft immer mehr
angewiesen sind und die uns wirklich am Herzen liegen, wie Batterieeffizienz, Finanzmodellierung und
Optimierung und sogar wie man bessere Flugzeuge baut. Also warum auf Quantencomputer setzen? Nun, wir haben sehr gute Gründe
zu glauben, dass hier viel Potenzial liegt, und wir können Türen zu neuer Berechnung öffnen, die derzeit selbst für die
leistungsstärksten Supercomputer unerreichbar ist. Theoretisch bieten einige Quantenalgorithmen Vorteile gegenüber den
besten möglichen klassischen Algorithmen für bestimmte Anwendungen. Für andere Anwendungen gibt es zunehmende Hinweise, dass
Quantencomputer selbst mit etwas Rauschen und Unvollkommenheiten als Werkzeug eingesetzt werden können, um mit klassischen Brute-
Force-Lösungen zu konkurrieren. Im Grunde ist es ein brandneues Werkzeug und wir wollen noch mehr coole Dinge herausfinden, die wir damit machen können. Aber wir können
auch auf Feynmans ursprüngliche Idee dafür zurückgreifen, nämlich sie zu nutzen, um Physik und Natur an sich zu verstehen.
Schließlich habe ich dir bereits gesagt, dass die Natur quantenmechanisch ist, nicht klassisch. Und dieses Feld ist unglaublich reich, faszinierend und
interdisziplinär. Es bringt Physik, Informatik, Informationsverarbeitung und natürlich die spezifischen Domänen der Anwendungsbereiche zusammen, die wir
interessant finden könnten. Im Gegensatz zu klassischen Computern hat aber nicht jeder einen Quantencomputer in der
Tasche. Bis vor kurzem musste man, wenn man mit einem Quantencomputer experimentieren wollte, einen selbst bauen und warten,
normalerweise in einem traurigen Kellerlabor einer Universität oder Forschungseinrichtung — und glaub mir, ich weiß das. Das ist
jetzt nicht mehr der Fall. 2016 brachte IBM den ersten Quantenprozessor in die Cloud. Er hatte damals nur fünf Qubits und
ziemlich hohe Fehlerraten, aber das war erst vor 8 Jahren, und schau, wie weit wir gekommen sind. Also wo stehen wir heute?
Es gibt viele Parallelen zu den sehr frühen Tagen des modernen Computers. Wie ich erwähnt habe, ist das eine sehr
schwierige Herausforderung, und erst in den letzten 8 Jahren wurden Quantencomputer allgemein verfügbar, abgesehen von
denen, die in einem Spitzenlabor oder einer Einrichtung arbeiten. Aber in diesen acht Jahren haben wir Fortschritte an jeder
Front gemacht. Prozessoren sind in der Qubit-Größe um Größenordnungen gewachsen. Gates sind deutlich verbessert und wir haben Methoden eingeführt,
um Fehler zu reduzieren oder zu mindern, die den Quantensystemen inhärent sind, auch während wir voranschreiten, fehlertolerante
Quantencomputer zu entwickeln. Jetzt kannst du und jeder andere einen dieser zahlreichen IBM Quantenprozessoren nutzen, die
in der Cloud gehostet werden, von denen fast alle die neuesten und besten Systeme mit über 100
Qubits sind. Aber es ist nicht nur die Größe der Prozessoren, die wichtig ist. Das ist nur eine Metrik, die uns interessiert, und
das ergibt Sinn, oder? Wenn wir mehr Qubits haben, ist das offensichtlich besser, vorausgesetzt, dass die Erhöhung der Qubit-Zahl
die Leistung nicht verschlechtert. Aber das ist nicht immer der Fall. Wir brauchen mehr Qubits von guter Qualität, die nicht miteinander
durch Crosstalk interferieren, wenn wir es nicht wollen. Wie die Qubits miteinander verbunden sind, ist auch etwas Wichtiges. In
supraleitenden Schaltkreisen ist es eine Herausforderung herauszufinden, wie man die Qubits am besten physisch verbindet. Eine weitere enorm wichtige Metrik
ist die Zwei-Qubit-Gate-Fidelity. Gates, die auf einzelnen Qubits laufen, sind nicht so fehleranfällig. Zwei-Qubit-Gates sind der viel
größere Problembereich und normalerweise eine der ersten Metriken, die wir betrachten, um zu sehen, wie sich die Leistung im Laufe der Zeit verbessert.
Zwei-Qubit-Gates richtig hinzubekommen ist entscheidend, weil sie für die Erzeugung von Verschränkung zwischen den Qubits verantwortlich sind,
was eines der physikalischen Phänomene ist, die Quantencomputern ihre Leistung geben. Schließlich achten wir auf Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz.
Wir müssen sicherstellen, dass die Zeit, die ein Programm auf dem Quantenchip verbringt, so schnell und so effizient
wie möglich ausgeführt wird. Wir bezeichnen diese drei Metriken zusammen als Skalierung, Qualität und
Geschwindigkeit. Alle sind entscheidend für die Verbesserung der Leistung. Jetzt möchte ich dir einige kurze Grafiken zeigen, um zu belegen, was ich
darüber gesagt habe, wie sich die Technologie selbst wirklich recht schnell entwickelt. Die Qubit-Anzahl selbst ist am einfachsten
zu verstehen, denke ich, und IBM hat eine Roadmap veröffentlicht, wo wir in den nächsten Jahren in Bezug auf Qubit-Anzahl stehen wollen.
Für 2024, als wir dieses Video drehen, sind wir genau auf Kurs mit unseren Prozessoren Heron und Condor. Als nächstes
Qualität: Diese Grafik zeigt die mediane Verschränkungs-Gate-Fehlerrate für IBM Quantenprozessoren über die Zeit. Beachte,
dass dies eine logarithmische Skala ist. Während der Fortschritt also vage linear aussieht, ist er tatsächlich viel schneller.
Schließlich Geschwindigkeit: Diese Grafik zeigt den Fortschritt einer Metrik, die wir CLOPS nennen, was für Circuit Layer
Operations Per Second steht. Entscheidend ist, dass CLOPS sowohl die Zeit, die zum Ausführen von Circuits benötigt wird, als auch die erforderliche Echtzeit- und
Nahezu-Echtzeit-klassische Berechnung umfasst. Im Grunde ist CLOPS ein Maß dafür, wie schnell unsere Prozessoren bestimmte Circuits in
Serie ausführen können, und dient als Maß für die ganzheitliche Systemgeschwindigkeit unter Einbeziehung von Quanten- und klassischem
Computing. Derzeit, zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme, ist IBM der einzige Quanten-Cloud-Anbieter, der Zugang zu 100+
Qubit-Maschinen bietet. Wie ich vor einigen Folien erwähnt habe, ist 100 Qubits oder ungefähr dort der Punkt, an dem klassische Simulation
vollständig versagt. Also haben große Jobs, die auf diesen Maschinen laufen, oft kein klassisches Äquivalent. Es ist
nicht möglich. Es gibt einige Nuancen und Tricks, um einige Teile eines Circuits zu simulieren und dann andere
Teile separat, aber im Allgemeinen wissen wir, dass ungefähr bei dieser Zahl Quantencomputer beginnen, Dinge zu tun, die klassische Computer einfach nicht können. Also
entschied IBM, dass es super wichtig für die breitere Community war, Zugang zu diesen größeren Geräten zu geben, weil alles,
was auf kleineren Geräten gemacht wird, klassisch simulierbar ist und somit nicht zu Quantum Advantage führen kann. Die 100-Qubit-
Geräte, die wir jetzt haben, sind immer noch fehlerhaft und immer noch verrauscht, also müssen wir klug sein, wie wir Jobs und
Circuits auf ihnen ausführen. Naiv einfach unseren Circuit zu schreiben und Shift-Enter zu drücken, wird wahrscheinlich zu nichts
Spektakulärem führen. Aber es gibt Tipps und Tricks, die wir anwenden können, und Best Practices, denen wir folgen können, um noch
mehr Leistung aus diesen Geräten herauszuholen, was hoffentlich schneller zu Quantum Advantage führt, auch während wir weiter
an unseren fehlertoleranten Maschinen arbeiten und bauen. Diese Grafik zeigt die Simulationskosten
oder die Zeit, die benötigt wird, um ein Problem auf klassischen Computern und Quantencomputern mit Fehler-
Minderung und Fehlerkorrektur zu lösen. Die Linie der klassischen Berechnung skaliert exponentiell mit wachsender Circuit-Komplexität.
Für einfache Circuits hier unten spielt das keine Rolle, aber es ist offensichtlich schlecht, wenn die Komplexität wächst, weil das
die Simulationskosten sehr schnell sehr teuer macht. Fehlerminderung skaliert besser, also wenn die Komplexität des
Circuits wächst, ist das der Bereich, in dem wir sein wollen. Wir befinden uns derzeit hier, mit klassischen Methoden und Quantenmethoden ungefähr
gleichauf für einige Anwendungen. Fehlerkorrektur ist vielleicht am bevorzugtesten und skaliert wirklich
gut — wir sind nur noch nicht so weit. In der Zwischenzeit werden wir uns weiter auf Fehlerminderung konzentrieren und versuchen, in diesen
Bereich der Quantum Utility so schnell wie möglich zu gelangen. Und indem wir verschiedene Fehlerminderungsverfahren nutzen, die wir
in dieser Serie kennenlernen werden, wollen wir Anwendungsbereiche finden, die sehr bald von Quantum Utility profitieren können. Und das ist
wirklich das Herz dieses Kurses. Wir haben diese Maschinen, wir denken, sie sind zu wirklich interessanter
Forschung fähig — also wie nutzen wir sie? In diesem letzten Abschnitt der Episode besprechen wir kurz Anwendungsbereiche für
praktisches Quantum Computing. Es gibt drei Hauptbereiche, die uns am meisten begeistern und in denen wir Wege für Quantum
Utility erkunden wollen. Der erste ist die Simulation der Natur. Das hat mit der Simulation molekularer oder atomarer Wechselwirkungen zu tun und ist
wirklich wichtig für die Materialwissenschaft und Chemie. Aus Gründen, die wir vorhin besprochen haben, denken wir, dass Quanten-
Computer darin viel besser sein werden als ihre klassischen Gegenstücke. Als nächstes kommt Suche und
Optimierung. Der wichtigste Algorithmus hier heißt QAOA, ein hybrider klassisch-quantenmechanischer Algorithmus. QAOA nutzt einen
klassischen Computer, um optimale Parameter für einen Quanten-Circuit zu finden, und wird hoffentlich viel
effizienter sein, als es jeder Computer allein könnte. Schließlich haben wir Mathematik und die Verarbeitung von Daten mit Struktur. Quanten-
Computer sind wirklich gut darin, Struktur in unübersichtlichen Daten zu finden, wo du, ich oder ein normaler Computer vielleicht
nichts sehen würden. Quantenmaschinelles Lernen ist vielversprechend in diesem Bereich und wir wollen es für Aufgaben wie Merkmals-
Extraktion und Mustererkennung nutzen. Es ist wirklich eine sehr aufregende Zeit für diejenigen von uns, die im
Bereich Quantum Computing arbeiten. Zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte können wir beginnen, einen Bereich des Computing zu erkunden, der jenseits
des klassischen Computing liegt. Diejenigen unter euch, die das hier schauen, spielen möglicherweise eine ähnliche Rolle wie die frühen Pioniere der
Computertechnik — und die hatten keine Vorstellung davon, was folgen würde. T. J. Watson von IBM sagte sogar einmal, er dachte, es gäbe
vielleicht einen Markt für nur zwei oder drei Computer überhaupt — und wie sehr lag er falsch. Wir
sind allesamt diese frühen Pioniere der Computertechnik, nur in diesem neuen Feld des Quantum Computing. Und Quantum wird oft
im Gegensatz zu klassischem Computing als etwas deutlich Verschiedenes davon dargestellt, oft in Konkurrenz damit. Aber mein
Ziel für diese Einführungsvorlesung war, dich hoffentlich davon zu überzeugen, dass wir aus der Vogelperspektive Quantum
Computing einfach als das nächste Kapitel in einer langen Geschichte der Berechnung sehen können. Es liegt in unserer Natur als Menschen, neue Wege zu
suchen, zu rechnen und die Kraft der Natur zu nutzen und herauszufinden, was wir damit machen können. Und das tun wir seit
Jahrhunderten. Quantum Computing bietet uns ein neues Werkzeug in diesem Bestreben, und es liegt an uns zu entdecken, wie wir
die Kraft nutzen können, die es uns bietet. In der nächsten Lektion der Serie werden wir etwas mehr über 100-Qubit-Systeme sprechen
und einen Überblick über Qiskit geben, unser Quanten-Software-SDK, und wie man diese Maschinen gerade jetzt am besten nutzt. Danke fürs
Zuschauen, und bis zum nächsten Mal.